part of the reason people are turned off  religion is because some people who are  religious don't know how to speak to  people who haven't experienced it at all  and not experiencing it means it's very  very difficult to understand i was  turned off of it from seeing like bumper  stickers from people that are like uh if  you don't have jesus then it's hell  and it's like  whether or not that's true that's not  how you get other people to understand  what you believe so i think people don't  identify as religious because we're  taught science and it doesn't really  make sense if you don't really think  about it and if you don't experience it  yourself  if someone just explains something by  saying well you know god or jesus it's  like what does that mean